the jurogan experience let me ask you a
real question because i haven't
asked you i saw that jake paul kid
chirping at your boy dc
yes what's the deal well he wants to
make some money
no i know he's a good shoe he's a good
show hello but what did dc say to him
dc said take my [ __ ] name out of your
mouth i'm not a kid
i will [ __ ] you up and he was like ikes
[ __ ] former ufc heavyweight champion
in the world yeah that's
not what you want but shout out i will
say this
[ __ ] kid knows how to piss everybody
off he's so good at it let me tell you
something dude
we were in florida in jacksonville sold
out arena
and they were all chanting [ __ ] jake
paul
[ __ ] jake paul he's filming it he's
loving him get his phone out he's like
yeah
because you know what you know what he's
hearing money jake paul jake paul no
he's hearing
should she yeah the whole time he's
making so much money dude
it was 1.5 million pay-per-view buys
when he knocked out ben
askren i don't know if that's true dana
white says it's nonsense
but maybe he doesn't i mean who has the
[ __ ] receipts
if he's telling the truth and you know
if he's lying why didn't he say two
million why do you say three million
right why say 1.5 i mean maybe he's
telling the truth if he's telling the
truth
they made a [ __ ] considerable amount
of money and that's
bigger by more than double the very
legitimate
three fight three title fight ufc card
of this past weekend
because that apparently got 700 000 buys
granted these are 700 000 espn plus
verified absolute buys
there's no [ __ ] right you know this
whole triller fight club thing is like
you know you got like rap music and a
bunch of other [ __ ] and you got this
trailer company which
a friend of mine who uh works in finance
explained to me what triller was
they trailer event now verify this see
if this is true
they were originally poised they put
together a company i don't know if this
is true
this is just what my friend told me
right that they put and my friends were
very smart
they put together this company because
tick tock was about to be banned from
the united states
and when tick tock was about to be
banned and uh josh rogan the
journalist explained to us that
[ __ ] that they
they almost had a ban but then they
tried to capitalize on it make money and
sell it to oracle's is
crazy [ __ ] but anyway when triller
triller was set to take over like hey
we're the new tick-tock
so they got a bunch of money together
and then the justice department or
whoever
decided not to ban tick-tock the thing
fell apart
tick-tock still here so they said we're
gonna put on fights
huh i don't know if that's true close
very close it was already an app going
around that was like a very small
competitor to tick-tock
based almost just like hip-hop music
only and then they expanded into video
other stuff and then that happened they
like were used because they were the
only like
us competitor so then they negotiated a
deal with
mike tyson to fight roy jones jr right
and that was his gigantic huge fight
that got over a million buys i believe
right
and i believed that i mean everybody
wanted to see what the [ __ ] was
happening there
and then mike tyson recently said he
wants nothing to do with them he's not
doing anything with them anymore
why don't something happen i don't know
i wonder the money wasn't
something happened with the money i have
no idea maybe got a better offer
somewhere else
maybe they didn't do do them justice
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience